e
and I'm not sure who's in camera
land right
now on this but I'm not I'm not going to
hold this up because of a because of of
a remote camera that's a remote camera
well because of the cameras yeah so all
right so I'm G to get creative here I'm
going to
open
subcommittee hearing on House Bill 2712
71 is a it deals with the licensing
requirements for licensed Social Work
Associates now the to remind everybody
the crusp of this was to remove exam
requirements for
lure we learned in testimony that
the exam requirement was instituted just
back in 20
21 uh it's it's still in its infancy
really and um we had you know testimony
um both in favor of removing
removing one of the concerns that I have
I'll open I'll just open up the
is we just in 2021 created the
requirement for
this it's really not had much of an
opportunity to get off the ground yet so
um when you have when you're when you're
granting
lure
to someone that comes with some
connotations some
expectations of of certain
things and
typically when you're license to do
something you've met some sort of
criteria
so I have
reservations in
this legislation because of that factor
and uh I'm curious as to what my
colleagues are thinking as well so I'll
open it up
groda thank you uh Mr chair so I agree
that when you have lure or you're
licensed to do something you should have
some way of measuring your um your
capability so that it meets
lure there
was I found that the testimony in
support of the bill was not
strong
because I got
conflicting it was it I am flicted as to
whether or not this is
supervision or a clerical
position and
regardless we typically don't support
lenser
without a measuring
insurance
coverage so I I need
some information and there's only is if
I if I remember correctly is there one
this does anybody have an IDE idea as to
why the bill that was passed a year ago
was oh I know why it was passed because
we wanted to have what I remember that
this was if my memory is correct this
bill was passed because we wanted
individuals to be licensed so that they
could these positions to be licensed so
they could
have um uh reimbursement capabilities
from the insurance company and when they
put them in put this Licensing in they
gave it a
hurdle and the concern is that the
unachievable
and is there data that that that I is
there data that shows
that maybe you can come up and talk and
but also introduce yourself
and we should probably have feel free to
come up um that's
okay
um you mentioned
data uh one of the things that the
lobbyist for the association of soci
social worker boards mentioned was that
due to the process of creating an exam
and going through all of that and
getting that all off the ground that's
only been in effect for six
months really so um and then that their
internal audit or their internal uh
question to their membership 78%
approved of of retaining the exam so
um I mean it's like I said was we're I
don't know the if we have enough data
here it's such it's such in its infancy
but but please provide what you
know is this on okay thank you chairman
thank you members of the committee my
name is Karina Bonia I work for caror
blue Strat IES um and John dejoy
representing the nasw New Hampshire who
brought this bill
forward so as mentioned there's only one
person in New Hampshire at the moment
who has an
lswa um so we don't have much data on
what
the the pass or fail rate is for the
exam at this moment but what we do know
is that right now what it calls for is
for individuals who are getting their Li
Social Work associate to take the exam
that's for the licensed social workers
and so the difference between those two
levels is that individuals who are
getting their licens their lssw who are
licensed as an license social work those
individuals have a bachelor's of social
work from an accredited institution
individuals who are getting their
licensed Social Work associate have a
bachelors's in some other fields other
than social work or an associates degree
in some human resources related field so
for an LSW someone with no formal Social
Work education from an accredited
institution to take that LSW licensure
exam that's where we expect um and
anticipate that there will be
some some difficulty in passing that
exam we even know that with the LSW exam
there are a number of individuals who
have a bachelor of social work from an
accredited institution who are still not
passing that exam and so we anticipate
that someone with no formal Social Work
education from an accredited University
will also find that to be a significant
lswa
okay representative long go for it uh so
I guess since they're different jobs
how relevant is the material on the
licensed social work exam to what LSW
are actually doing dayto day yeah so as
thank you for your question
representative long as something with
the lswa and the exam is that you'll see
in the requirements for an lswa it's not
just the lure exam there's also 30 hours
of required training as well as a
significant number of of train um
supervised hours with your
supervisor and the reason for that the
reason of those 30 hours of required
training is because if you have if
you're called a licensed Social Work
associate yet you don't have a formal
Social Work education it's important
that you understand the social work
field and what it means to have that
title and so in that 30 hours of
training those LS swas are getting
critical education into Social Work
competencies in the social work
education the roles of these individuals
are really in roles case
managers and so when you think about
social work as a field and the positions
of these individuals any person who's
doing direct service and um human
engagement
is you know essentially overlapping with
what the social work profession stands
for and what our what our values
are you know like working with people
engaging with community members if
you're a case manager and you're working
in a department that provides
Clin um that provides essential
resources to someone you're working with
a Community member it's important you
know the social work values of community
engagement working with Community those
values are essentially there but no CL
you don't have any Social Work education
hi hi
so we need to talk in more concrete
terms because this kind of yeah you're
so if you're saying that a a license
associate expectation to pass this Lo
the social
worker uh professional test okay
licensed social worker test is too high
a
bar do you have data that shows that or
you don't have any do you have anybody
who applied for that licensed social
worker associate and where they were
unable to pass the test I do not have
that data right now okay so I think that
would be helpful to have y and then if
we have don't you think I think that
would be helpful to have and if you
don't have that or for some reason that
doesn't
exist um there has to be
something other
than just checking off a bunch of boxes
and saying okay you're certified to be
an lswa you want so I would I'm willing
to um entertain a
discussion and some feedback from the
licensed social worker group that would
say okay this this doesn't work but this
would we just can't have a
certification I don't believe without
something that shows that you're capable
of that
certification to mean that doesn't
that's the whole point of a
certification or a license she says that
you were able to do this thing does that
make sense to you yes that makes sense
and I think that the intent is the 30
hours of training as well as the
significant numbers of supervision and
individuals with an lswa would never be
working unsupervised they would always
be working supervised by a licens
independent clinical social worker or
another supervisor who's able to oversee
their work they would never be working
independently without
supervision and where is that
written let me confirm for you I will
confirm where that is written while
you're looking at that I'm uh I spent a
lot of time in Academia I have an
engineering degree I did graduate work
at Oklahoma State University I have a
master's degree I so what I I try
to
balance different types
of
educational Adventures okay 30 hours is
a 4-day
so
balancing that and I appreciate the
Apprentice part of part of what you're
saying I maybe it's an old term we're
not using anymore but that's kind of
um as far as working
the watchful eye of of someone
else um that is
um
very agency
dependent right I mean the watchful eye
is varies okay
and the the concept of lure does bring
on certain public expect ations whether
they are real or not right now as a as a
wonderful example we all have a dri most
of us have a driver's license right well
that doesn't necessarily mean we're all
very good at driving so um so so
sometimes that can go a little bit of
skew but when it comes to Professional
Licensing I think we do have a little
so I think that you might have a point
here in five
years when you actually have some data
and you're not trying to repeal
something that has been in effect for
six
months I think that's that's the hangup
right now so
um I mean that that's that's where I'm
leaning with this and and I can see why
the association of social worker boards
opposes this I I get what they're saying
with this
um now if if this type of work
was was modified out of the word license
into something else then I think a
discussion could be had there
but that that term puts you at a certain
level now with that we talked about the
compact right because
compacts oh yeah there is there is a
compact so we've we''ve
had compacts in New Hampshire that have
worked out okay we've had a couple that
have been Absolute Total disasters for
New Hampshire so every time that we get
into the weeds sideb barring compact
which I know there was some discussions
I asked the question about the
compact we now it appears there's not
consistency between states in this
compact as far as those things that
really gets my blood pressure up on on
the concept of a compact that does not
have uniformity across its
membership because now we are allowing
in theory someone to come in or we're
exporting someone right because
hopefully we're doing hopefully New
Hampshire's contributing right where the
the playing field is not as questionable
here
so I I think it's just too early it's
just that simple it's just too early to
to pull the plug on this um until we we
can have something tangible to show
not and I'd love to hear what Glenn
so in reference to competency which I
think is what you're getting at right I
mean showing competency without
education versus showing Education
Without
competency I think the default is to
lean towards competency regardless of
how you get it people learn differently
here and again requirements of
educational the bachelor's degree
requirement is a is a broad one right
it's because you can be in the field or
outside the field right you can have a
bachelor's degree in another practice to
get an lswa yep yep okay so it means
that you don't have a bachelor's degree
in social work and you obviously don't
have a masters in social work clearly
ybody did not the UC I'd say you would
not be as good because you fa because
the other person failed it I mean we
don't write the exam the legislature
doesn't dictate the contents of that
board yeah
yeah absolutely representative gr thank
you
so it is not
unusual that in our
licensing levels we have associate
levels
and uh the level above whatever that is
associate the I'm remembering also the
level is not one
that as that often people leave that
level to go to the next level because in
order is that right yes you cannot I
remember this did come up um in our
initial public hearing about if this is
a stepping stone and it's really not you
cannot become you cannot go from being
an lswa to an lssw or from an lswa to an
LCSW without the education so to go from
an lswa to an LCSW you would need to
have a m you need to have a bachelor's
degree at least and then you would need
to get your masters in social work um so
this is a step Stone in the way of when
you have a license it's empowering and
you might go on to receive a formal
Social Work education and then aim for
other lur teers but there is no way to
go from being an LSW to then get a
promotion and now you've moved
up sure and that that representative
long
so as have two questions first is there
some other exam that might be a better
fit for this position that could be
required instead or some practical
skills
that might need to be
demonstrated uh and then I guess you
know I'm interested in the idea of doing
something other than a license if that
would help but I guess what is what do
the insurance companies actually
require um in order to get reimbursed is
there some alternative available that
would actually fit that fill that need
so the original creation I'm I'm not
sure what the insurance companies need
the actual original bringing in of the
LSW and lswa tiers was done without the
nasw's um buyin uh we didn't find out
about it until after the amendment was
passed
so those tiers were sort of created with
new Futures with the intention of
billing first services to these
individuals who are doing this essential
work that's mirroring Social Work type
of Engagement um and giving it that like
adding those additional lured tiers but
that was not done with the N
nasw's um buyin so I'm not sure what the
requirements are necessarily
for to for the insurance companies and
to be reimbursed and build um and then
you can you remind me of your other
question representative long
so my other question was whether there's
some other test that might be a better
fit for the position whether it's an
academic test or practical skills test
uh that would actually just be more
relevant to what people in this position
are doing um and maybe less of a barrier
to people who are actually qualified for
it yeah I think um that would be a
really great road to go down and
amendment to consider I'm not sure what
that would look like exactly or what
that might exactly be I think um part of
that proving that you're able to do the
work is before you're licensed you're
doing the work always in supervision
even after you're licensed but before
you become licensed if you have a
bachelor's you have to do I'm looking at
the facts so that I'm telling you
exactly the truth if you have a
bachelor's you would do 4,000 hours
supervised before even being licensed as
an lswa and if you have your Associates
that would be 6,000 supervised hours
before ever even being licensed and I
think that what we talked about earlier
is to really ensure that you are
competent in the work and able to do
this prior to lure and then once
licensed you would continue to be
work okay
so so there's nobody here from oplc that
I thought I thought it was you I said I
think that's that's so could we ask you
a
you so where is this these hours
documented the the hours that she
mentions as far as hours of supervision
or the hours of apparently there are
other other than this test in order to
become a licensed social worker
associate yep you need hours of
something yes that it would that's in
the requirements for lure so I don't I
don't have the mechanics I could get
back to you on is that tracked directly
is it just an attestation I did it is it
a form that fills out the required hours
there um I I don't have the mechanics in
front of me but I could get that for you
that would be helpful thank you yeah
totally
is there any any other contexts that you
need from
me no I mean other than you know again
we're we're
meddling in a profession that has a
compact and I am
always
hesitant
to you got to be careful right because
we've agreed to join a compact which has
conditions and requirements and
expectations and
and you know that's that's one of the
reason there are people that do not like
entering into compacts because you have
to now tiptoe a little bit and you know
the the consistency issue with this exam
that was brought forward during the
public hearing was problematic to me
right from the get-go in the fact that a
compact's been created that that has a
requirement that is not NE
necessarily in well it's not even that
it's not enforced it's that it's it may
or may not be required depending on the
state that's in the compact so and I'm
not here to to litigate the Compact and
this deficiency that I think exists
within the compact right because with
other compacts you have you know Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam this is what we require all
the way across the board and so when
we're getting someone from another state
we have a minimum level of expectation
and vice versa this exam seems to fall
outside of
those requirements where some states
want it some states don't so in the
interest of keeping a
bar for New
Hampshire at at a better
level in the infancy of this I I'm very
very hesitant to start changing what
we've what we've done what we've agreed
to God bless you at the beginning so you
oplc has to run you guys have got to
manage this compact you have to manage
the all of this
so that's that's kind of why you have to
show up to these yeah I can I can take a
little bit of a step back and just kind
of talk through so I think I think the
origin of this particular piece of
legislation you're considering is
because um and I think you alluded a
little bit to the the fact that the some
of the movement legislatively when it
was passed was um it was not as robust a
stakeholder engagement as it might have
been and so I think there were some
stakeholders who would have liked to be
included and to say hey do we do we want
the same Examination for this level of
lure as for the next one up so if you
have like a master's level social worker
and then you have a bachelor's level and
then you have this which is an associate
or some kind of alternate
piece should there not
be the the rigor and the level of
examination or competency would be
different for those three and I think
what they're saying is that having it be
the same for the bachelor's level as for
this other one is um I think that's the
concern now I again I don't have metrics
I can't weigh in on that but I think
that's the piece of it and I think um
it's possible that discussion would have
been had before this bill was passed in
that time to say is this the mo most
appropriate way to measure that
competency um and then I was going to
address your compact piece just a a
little bit to say um generally the way
that compacts are are working is you if
New Hampshire enters the social work
compact you can get a compact license
but you don't have to right so you you
can have a compact license with
standards but you you don't have to get
a compact license so the standards for
New Hampshire for an regular New
Hampshire license can stay so I don't I
I understand that well in my ideal World
there wouldn't be two different criteria
right just in terms of administration
but but there could be and and that
would be okay so um just a few things to
chew on so
it sounds
like the
board it sounds like the if the Board
needs to create an exam for that level
right if if they have an exam that's
that's far above that's kind of outside
their world then it sounds to me like
the Board needs to address that and
right because we don't dictate the
contents of the exam that's that's not
what we do here what we're discussing is
whether an exam exists or exists or not
thank God we don't write them right we
you don't want to do that holy crap
right we don't know what we're doing
with that but
it's it's the idea it's the go no go
idea do do we have a license or do we
not so you know I I think it's clear
that there seems to be a need for it but
if the if the exam to get to that is
just not appropriate let's address that
right and
that is outside the scope of of us that
that's a the board that's involved with
that will need to do that and if and if
they can come come up with something
that and bring people together and say
okay this is this is more in tune to
what we do then when you've done it come
back to the legislature and make
whatever
tweaks need to be made if if at all then
that might be more
uh uh I the board is not going to
develop an exam without the legislative
authority to develop exam and give it so
unless you say there needs to be this
level exam developed that it's not going
to happen so we could but it might be in
a I don't we're not the boards do write
questions for some exams but many of
them are National exams so it might be
more of a national piece to say we we
need an assessment that's appropriate
that is standard across the board I
don't know if that exists at that level
I'd be happy to share the table with my
colleague here if if we'd like to have
that discussion but um so I have a
suggestion yeah what we could do is we
can write legislation that gives the
authority to the board to write the
making which we we could do that and
then they would have to bring those
rules to they'd have a hearing and that
input and then it could be whatever they
decide is the right criteria for so it
gives the board the authority to do that
in rule making so it could just say an
ex the perhaps a statutory change could
just be a little bit more generic about
an exam and not name the specific exam
and then create the ru making authority
to develop or even have to be an exam
we're just giving you the CR the
authority to write the criteria in rule
making you can be whatever you want it
to be I it can't be you know just just
know that there has to be something M
right I and uh maybe it would be helpful
for the subcommittee if I um if I Just
sh I mean I I could go back to my
computer and probably pull it up and
share the criteria that already is in
rule for this to take a look there I
don't I don't know if when you're
planning to make a decision or um the
bring it back to full committee but I I
could get you some information about
what's already in rule for for
ultimately this this the subcommittee
will bring forward things to the full
committee to discuss within the
executive session okay so that there's
but I
would the way I would write enabling Le
legislation in the event that it is
necessary to create or
adopt right because again we're not
asking anybody to reinvent the wheel
if the wheel already exists right and
that I mean the compact references
already
references an exam so that's that's why
compacts get messy right so if the
compact already has an exam and you have
to take that exam to have a compact
license as we've as we know there's two
levels are we are we now forcing the
board to create something simply just to
when we don't necessarily need to and
that's okay so yeah and presently in the
in the law there's it does still have
meet other criteria as established by
the
board
so
that that kind of gives that rule making
piece so what I'd like to do is pull and
see what we have listed in the rule
already
to to let you know what there is already
in place what those standards are um I
guess ASE
presently it does say pass pass a
national Proctor proctored examination
approved by the board and I think the
challenge is that there's there is no I
think the issue actually is that there
is no National exam for this level of
lure I I think that's the Crux of the
issue yeah uh also representative groda
it is chapter 330a a8c is the license
Social Work associate and at the bottom
it says a licensed Social Work associate
May engage in practice only under
clinical supervision of a licensed
clinical social worker a licensed mental
health counselor um and so that's where
it says concrete that even after
obtaining your lswa with your 3,000
hours you still may only practice under
the supervision of somebody who is
licensed
and that's again looking can you use the
microphone because nobody out there can
hear you so
um so it s if they have meet other
criterias established by the board I I
think that gives them a green light on
that one um the but the requirement of
meeting
the the
this is what we run into in O you and I
talked about this before with other
boards having requirements listed for
things that either don't
exist right or have been modified so
much now they don't apply right so it
sounds like we're this is another one
where we're
just where if if that's the gig if
that's the requirement now that that's a
compact requirement though
not not not a New Hampshire requirement
I think what I would say is um it we're
not about Reinventing the wheel around
here I think literally when the
associate license was created it was a
copy and paste from the licensed
clinical social worker put it here same
thing so the I think the if I'm
adequately representing the position is
to say we we needed to do a little more
thinking than copying and pasting from
that same level because maybe this exam
doesn't exist maybe that level of
testing is not required for this type of
work because it is under supervision at
all times so uh I can Implement whatever
you give me but presently I can issue a
license without an exam for this level
with the statute as it currently stands
so it sounds like that the direction is
clear here that coming come up with what
needs to exist and then come to us and
we'll change it okay we're not going to
dump it and then hope that something
gets enacted I'll leave that to my
lobbyist Nationals a friends I don't you
don't want me in the business of doing
that but yes I I as a director you don't
do that no no no yes but you see what
I'm saying I see what you're saying yes
is before before we eliminate the exam
make sure that there's measures in place
to ensure that individuals getting an
lswa have a process in place
to confirm their competency and make
sure that they're able to do the job
before we eliminate something violating
the compact
y I mean this is and you got to convince
the board to do this right this is this
is why oplc exists this is why we have
57 boards the
boards the boards have to regulate their
Industries right you don't want the
legislature regulating your industry and
taking over the a Board responsibility
because we're we're not you're not going
to like what happens the the other piece
I'll just add is um I I do my director
of Licensing Bethany catell is is
regularly engaged on the social work
compact because they're they're working
on that language now she's going to
meetings regularly and what I can do is
have her reach out to the other states
that are engaged in that conversation
and see what the criteria and what other
states are doing if we're looking at
kind of that National piece because it
sounds like if New Hampshire's having
that problem fitting the job with the
exam are the is are other states having
the exact same questions that we're
having y yep and and I would be shocked
if they're not
so it sounds like we have a pathway to
fix this
yep just so just for the
timing might it be possible that we'll
get an amendment from you or a
suggestion for Amendment from you in the
next week or so or a couple of
weeks I think you're looking at a
tremendous amount of board work and
discussion I in that I'm just asking
because then then if we don't do that
then I think we make we want to retain
the bill because we certainly don't want
to kill it and then we would work on it
we would give them the opportunity to
come back next year that's what I'm yeah
I mean we'll talk with the chair uh as
to whether just if retention is is the
appropriate way to do this or if it's
just a matter of refiling right in the
in the fall with something else I'll
I'll talk with her about it but um but
that's that's that's how we see this so
so so House Bill 271 is not not the way
to get that done but but I think we I
think we can get to where we need to be
it's just it's just going to take a
little bit of finagling so yeah I think
the only VAR variable would be when if I
say here's the rules of the criteria
that they've established and you got you
as the subcommittee and the committee
feel comfortable that that's enough to
strike it then you wouldn't need an
amendment you could rely on those
criteria so I I think there is a
possibility that you could take that to
a full committee and I can provide that
to I I could provide that to you in the
next 15 minutes so you can gauge your
comfort level there sure and and I think
as a committee right when we get into
executive session we can discuss what
what this board is allowed to do yeah
right right now and then if and if
that's enough to to get us down that
road then the board's got some work
ahead of it right well the the board
right now per the statute can only can
approve a national exam
if a national exam does if a lower
National exam does not exist the board
the board is just approving its option
in in front of it if that makes sense so
meet other criterias established by the
board is not
enough well so the the one that the the
bill is my understanding is proposing to
strike the you know to successfully
complete the exam that's approved by the
board so the board has the authority to
approve a national appro to approve a
national exam so they could pick from
the array but they probably have picked
the one that's available to them and the
the policy decision is is that
appropriate the board wouldn't be able
to invent a new National
exam sure yeah so th this is where this
is where we get grumpy with OSS right
because you you provided OS if you're
watching you provided us a bill that
strikes out two pieces of legislation
right it would have probably been nice
it probably would have been smart to put
what that is yeah right because it's
it's it's not here so the whole
paragraph would have probably been a
better choice with strikethroughs rather
than just just that so um but cool all
right so I think we're I think we've got
it we've got some things figured out
here and and uh and we'll go from there
so when when this does come to the exact
session d i we're going to need your
Clarity on on we will be there on their
Authority awesome thank you
thank you does anybody else have
anything they want to add to this okay
wonderful what's our
recommendation our
recommendation right now is I think that
the recommendation is we're going to
have an INF full executive committee
discuss what we just discussed here with
with the input from oplc as to whether
or what Authority that board
has to make changes because if if they
if they don't
and they're stuck by either compact
requirements or or their only
requirement is that they can pick an
exam then we're kind of handcuffed
either we're we're removing the exam or
we're
not
okay and we'll go from there right I
mean that's the legislation in it of
itself only stri is attempting to strike
out something so either we agree to
strike it out or we don't but we're kind
of doing them a solid here in the sense
that if we have the ability to amend
this and the committee's agreeable to
that then it's a discussion to have at
the with the entire executive board or
not the executive board the entire uh
board and or committee and executive
session okay well my understanding of a
subcommittee is the one is that we do
the work and then we make the
recommendation to the board so I'd like
to see what the amendment would be like
so that we could prepare the amendment
and bring it to the subcommittee to the
executive session are you saying that
we're going to do that if we're going to
do that then we'll we would have to
probably do this one more time unless we
can we'll go into recess and then NFD
can come up with that while we're
sitting here I think representative
scitec has a
representative they're on the other the
other
one sure can you come up here so that
you don't have to like scream and we
don't we can listen I know but come on
up our friend our representative friend
from
Salem I'm not a big fan of compacts
they're necessary evils so at the
considerable risk of uh agreeing with
the chair the thing that occurred to me
is if this is only the narrow issue of
the
exam I'm not a fan of exams that shows
you that you've done a good job with the
exam more than any profession I can
think of there should be an oral
component I don't know if there is one
where a skilled Board of
examiners asks puts people asks
questions and puts them as as much as an
oral can do into a real life situation
with the sufficient skill to irritate
the qu person being questioned to see
how they react this is in you're dealing
with this is People to People contact
you want you want warm
fuzzy heart and a hard
brain you want somebody that's engaging
that's warm that encourages trust but
the the person's watching the audience
is watching the person that they're in
ch in charge of so that can steer a
Direction
so my pitch is so the as you know
represent scitech the criteria is is
more than just the exam there'ss
absolutely it's a component I'm going to
throw into the mix that I think there
should be an AAL component retention is
a great idea but before you do any
amendments I'm not clear that you guys
have a real policy agreement or sense
yet no we're no we're it's going to
we're still chugging along and and
hoping to get some clarity from oplc on
whether or not we can even do that
absolutely so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put 271 in recess we'll get
into 145 that way we're not we don't
just wait because there's other folks
here to to um get into house bill 145
so let me open the hearing on house the
subcommittee hearing on House Bill
145 house bill for the reminder
of the millions around the world that
watch us on uh
YouTube
145 is relative to the background checks
of the licensed
dieticians and adopting a dietician lure
compact
one of the things that
um we we had several folks coming in on
both sides of this
um and there was the phrase privilege to
practice model that was stated several
times
so this
is again all these compacts are
different I wish you know you kind of
wish there was like a c a cookie cutter
way of doing these so you could just sit
there and go okay compact this compact
that but since they're all different um
my notes is I'm refreshing myself 10
states have filed four states have
agreed which is not we're not there yet
on a compact but that's how all compact
start um
reciprocity we do have reciprocity
now but you would have to meet the
second State's requirement which is how
in the old days of reciprocity that's
um that's that's where we are here and
there was some concern because this is
the compact right that we've got the 20
plus Pages or um you know the right out
of the gate the use of the word office
there seemed to be
some some issue with that and then of
course the big discussion really seemed
to center around paragraph three which
involved FBI's background
checks and the FBI reluctance or concern
about releasing their findings
to a
nonspecific person on the receiving end
now I think that that can be handled
fairly easily the HR Director the
there's I think we can name somebody
right I don't I don't but there seemed
to be some hang up with when it came to
time um involving that and then we did
have some discussion of the necessity of
background checks even existing here so
I am going to open this up
to anyone who wants to render an opinion
on what
happened and if how they saw things
representative groa thank you so
typically compact discussion are quite
dull but I have to tell you that at this
particular hearing we had many
dieticians come and testify in favor of
the compact this is something that they
want they they ask me to it is my bill
so do I have to I get to speak right
okay and
I and I out of um support out of the
dietician um profession entered the bill
I also told them that this was their
lift they needed to do it and they have
done it I think that there is confusion
in the industry as to what a dietician
is as opposed to somebody that you talk
to if you want to go on a diet that is
not the same
thing right they are not Nutri they are
not nutritionists these people people
work in hospitals they work in medical
areas they are not people that you talk
to if you want to go on a low carb diet
or gluten-free diet or anything like
that so I and they are here to testify
and to talk with us so I would invite
them Mr chair at your
discretion yeah absolutely I you know
I'm not like I said I'm always very
hesitant with compacts but I'm not
anti-c compact I think compacts serve a
purpose purp and and um if they're
withdraw all right thank you
representative tiek um you know I did
ask that question during the hearing
where in this compact does New Hampshire
have the right to exit that is found on
page 20 we it is there so so that's
really you know my my general concern
some compacts when you get into them
there are
incentives for being early if you will
um you you see that some compacts have
it where you know if you're the first
eight states you're you get to sit at
the big boy table sort of and and direct
um you know compact creation policies
and things like that we didn't really
have any discussion of that as far as
this goes and and you're more than
welcome to come up if you're familiar
with this if if that if there's I didn't
see that in here it may not exist in
this compact but
um button yep and just remind me who you
are okay I am Kate fifel I am a
dietician I do work at conquered
hospital but I'm not here representing
the hospital I'm here representing the
New Hampshire chapter of the Academy of
nutrition and dietetics um yes there is
an incentive to be one of the first
seven states to pass the compact lure it
gets you a seat at the commission to
form the commission and be part of the
rulemaking process so that would be um
something that we are definitely sure
highly interested in since we were here
for the public hearing um just to note
in New England both Maine and Rhode
Island have made it into session which
are neighbors um there are currently 14
States in session now since that hearing
total and there are four that have
passed and I've heard through the gra
fine one more is about to be signed um
and another just passed a subcommittee
so they're moving rapidly we' like to be
one of the first seven to get a seat at
that table um and I'm sorry if that
wasn't relayed
previously yeah I think we we got we got
kind of focused on on a couple of of
issues that seem
to Garner discussion at the when we were
at the public hearing um of course the
question that is always asked and it's
it's a we're at the point now where we
should open with what this does to
military folks that that every single
compact we enter into that question is
asked um that is addressed in section
six that's correct rate that's gets that
whole problem out of the way so I mean
the whoever drafted the the initial
compact proposal here um I can tell by
looking at it that they were not a
novice at this whoever did it right
because the things that we've seen that
were problematic in other compacts that
are addressed in
here the only one like I said that we
really
got stuck on was when it came to the
thank you when it came to the
um the criminal history part I I am not
a fan of dumping that I I think the
background checks have a a very
important place here we've had some
we've had some problems in New Hampshire
yes with not related to this field in
any way shape or form but in other
fields of people border hopping in their
jobs and escaping their path
by jumping around New England in a
circle yes right no we're not making
that mistake again so
the the that is addressed with this
compact it is and yes and the the
criminal history part of this also helps
in the sense that you're you're bringing
forward you're not hiding convictions or
problems that that
happened but again you know when the
officer um stated that they routinely
see issues with the FBI coming back and
bringing things because of a nondescript
they don't want to just randomly give
these out so it sounds like that's very
fixable we would need to
amend
this if we're able to and the reason I
say if is because sometimes with these
compacts if they're if they are what's
being drawn up universally amongst the
states it is a go or no go agreement
right it I'm I'm I've been counseled
through our Nationals they are working
on this it can be amended and they
actually are having conversations along
with other entities such as the Council
of state government they're working with
Congress they're trying to get some of
these issues resolved on a national
level not just related to dieticians in
our compact so it sounds to me and if I
remember correctly if we can address the
the paragraph three really um and not
use the term the office and we get a
specific release of this and we'll work
with the oplc director to get who that
whatever the title is of the person
whether a human resources or compliance
officer security officer whatever
whatever the term is but if we can
narrow that down to something specific I
think that solves the problems that
we're addressed in the public hearing
with
delaying this process because if the FBI
takes forever with this and they're not
even comfortable releasing it all this
stops because you got to paragraph 3 and
it's over so
um that that's what I see representative
groda did you guys see any other
concerns other than that part of that
that you think needs to be tweaked no I
don't think so and if if a if um
director jurus has a solution to that
looks like she
might yeah I was actually I was going to
make a note to say so it it appears to
me that
the the first section about the criminal
history record
checks is unrelated to the compact so
what I what I was suggesting if the
committee might be amendable the
subcommittee is we we're going to have
to look at some language per the
department of safety for a number of the
the language there's quite a bit of
language in the other bills that you had
heard so what I what I was thinking was
perhaps that section of about background
checks could actually be part of an
amendment with the language we're
working on for all of those other pieces
on another bill the committee is
currently considering that we're doing
cleanup language in and then you could
keep the the compact clean and just
leave it
separate a humble suggestion okay on
process let me just for clarity just so
I'm understanding what you're saying
um what what I'm hearing you're saying
is that you want a un
uniform the background check
language amongst many of
these because we have problems not just
this one yes okay that's I like that and
there's another bill before the
committee that you'd had you've had a
public hearing on it's currently in
committee that has because we use the
identical language everywhere in statute
for these and we're still not confident
that the FBI is going to approve but
based on the best guidance we have we
have language that we're preparing for
those other sections in the other bills
so what I if the committee was open to
it we could amend this one to repeal
that section in this bill leave the
compact all alone and then tie that
piece in as part of a further Amendment
where I'm making those other adjustments
in the cleanup language so then then you
could skip all the controversy and then
own yep can you is that the is is that
um representative Maguire in my bill
could you know what that that bill
number is I think that's it's either 82
or 85 yes one of the two and I think
that one is come is is both of those
okay they're both here so what we could
do is if we have an amendment for when
when we have that subcommittee hearing
you might bring that
Amendment and then we could okay yeah we
can shoot we can solve all that solve
all of those problems in one shot so we
could just continue this bill to that
subcommittee hearing we could
representative Bailey you just trying to
remember it seems to me we've
Consolidated a lot of things over the
last few years and some of them said
office and some of them said director
and some of them said this one and that
one and that that we were trying to I
think the one they settled on was to say
director and then that assumes everybody
under the director too as the Director
is responsible the problem that it
appears is that that is too broad for
what the FBI is looking for um but what
I what I do think part of the reason
oplc was created was for uniformity and
consistency across things so if if we
can come up or they can come up with an
acceptable way of of writing this part
of it and apply it across the board I
think that's helpful that's helpful for
everybody and then and then also on top
of that right you go to the FBI with
whoever the guinea pig is whichever one
ends up going first if you get the green
light on that I would like to think that
that would speed things up for everybody
else because they've already approved
that language it's uniform across the
board yeah it it's very much a moving T
Target uh right now and representative
Bailey I was just to your point is very
well taken I think it is interesting to
say when you say the office of the
executive director you're right it it
means anybody who's doing the work so
the FBI taking issue with the word
office when in reality it's the same
function I I don't know the statutory
construction I think is pretty clear but
uh we're going with the best guidance we
have right now so representative long
sure so what specifically is the I
challenge with getting firmer guidance
from the FBI about what they want uh and
is there reluctance is it based in a
statute a regulation is there some
underlying document that you could look
at to determine what exactly they need
we are asking the same question that you
are of the Department of Safety we want
to work collaboratively we were not
aware until the public hearing that that
was an issue so we we've been in
conversation with them I think the
reason we're not getting Clarity is
because when we ask for clarity they
point us to the rule or um the RSA and
it clearly states that it can be a
government entity
but then when we put a government entity
in the statute they say it's too broad
so that is the Crux of the challenge so
we we're trying to do based on safety's
knowledge of the review to say what what
they think is close or is going to pass
that's the best we can
do but we have the same questions I can
tell you attorney fry is extremely
frustrated So when you say oplc that's
too broad but if you said director of
oplc would that ding that's the one or
that's the guidance that we've been
given don't you love
bureaucracy it's is classic example yes
now now within within your office do you
have someone that falls under the title
of either HR Director compliance officer
someone someone that has something
specific that seems to fall in line as
to what they're looking for does that
oplc there are positions that are title
similar to that but those are not the
credentialing you know these are I don't
have my HR Director reviewing cbc's for
every licy that's what licensing clerks
do it seems as
though what there what they need is they
need someone to they're looking for some
specific title to deliver these
background checks too once you receive
those what you do internally with those
is
up to
you once the FBI releases them to the
oplc whoever that is you do what you do
I don't I don't there's no there's no
chain of custody type stuff here with
this so don't don't quote me on this I'm
not I'm not an attorney or really an
expert in this FBI thing there there is
um there's a Prohibition on secondary
dissemination I mean there's a lot these
this is really tightly regulated um and
there there's a lot there there's a lot
of mixed signals would say but uh if the
committee would like we can we can
continue this discussion when we're
dealing with the other language and the
other Bill and um I know you guys have
had a long day so I think safy would be
better to answer these questions than
than me quite frankly I I'm just telling
you what they've told me I mean safety
was that was they don't like this that's
what they said okay well what do they
like and that's where things kind of
fell short y so we have some language to
propose to um to you that we think meets
what they've asked for and I can include
this section with the other ones that
we've been working on okay
representative Bailey so some people are
already in this compact right and so
what are they doing no the compact has
not taken effect yet because they have
not met the minimum threshold for States
agreeing that this they're creating the
pie right now they just haven't made the
slices this is completely separate from
the compact this is just additional
language that if you read the bill it
says information it says background
checks and the compact so the compact is
a separate Clause it has nothing to do
with the compact okay thank you
yeah in the legislation the compact
begins uh paragraph four right this is
over and above but I was just thinking
hello guys what are you doing as as it
is as it is as this legislation is
written we do have to address it one way
or the other to right I I I don't think
it's a hang up on passing the compact
it's just right let's let's just get in
it get it straightened out and and we'll
have that consistency yep so in the
spirit of something that we did last
session in oplc in in Edna with when we
wrote House Bill 655 was to take out the
administrative functions of the boards
and put them under the direction of the
office and this and as a result of that
there was a lot of cleanup that had to
happen and we've been slowly getting
through that and this background check
information falls in the office
baileywick so we should definitely take
it out of this bill and put it in the
other and add it so that all of the
background checks will be handled the
same way so if you have that
language if you could bring it to the
next subcommittee meeting we could um
have an amendment for that and we would
we would amend this bill by taking that
out takeing taking the background check
part out okay taking the background
check part out may be problematic for
some no it's just going to go in a
different
Bell no hold on a second the the D the
modification of that you're you're
talking about putting into a separate
bill if you remove the criminal
background checks out of this then
you've removed the requirement of
background checks for this and that's
not that's no no no no no we're not
doing that oh I see what you're saying
we're just going to copy and paste we're
just going to C we just amend this cut
cut and paste cut out of
hb45 and paste in HB 82 yeah that's
we're just going to cut and paste all in
the committee you're not eliminating the
background check you're just modifying
the language so that it is consistent
across you use like a computer sense is
where you use a go-to like you have a
piece of Statute says this is the
background check and then all these
other things point to that RSA piece or
and in a perfect world that's exactly
how you would do it because then if you
have to make changes to it you make
changes to one part of Statute and then
it's all referenced so how do we do that
we had too much Frankenstein going on
for that I got 60 different practice
acts but I hear you I would love that
someday that's that would be a dream
that can that's one of those bills that
comes in on a second year that's this
thick which we which we've done before
right correct but you would that but
again you're 57 boards that's 57 Boards
that sure yep so I agree with the
director that that's that is a fight
it's coming it's not today they're not
ready for that yet
so so that would I so I guess then the
recommendation of this subcommittee then
paragraph section one paragraphs 1 2 and
that I don't know I don't like the way
they wrote this just the way they
chopped out the paragraphs because the
section one should just be
the the criminal background part of it
and then it then the compact should
begin at section two and they just
didn't write it that way would yeah they
just they just didn't write it that way
would the subcommittee like attorney fry
to take a stab at the two different
amendments and hand them both at the
same time so you look at them next to
each other i' I'd be happy to ask him to
do that sure that'd be great yep yep you
feel confident I know what you want okay
yeah well again it's not necessarily
what we want we want this to work we
want this to not be an incumbrance upon
the process right if because if you if
you're going to require background
checks the process has to function so um
but I do agree I do agree with
representative Bailey very much in the
sense that if if we're going to have the
if if we're going to have the language
the language has to be the same across
the board and the ability to change it
if if there are problems that come up
later needs to be not a 275 page bill it
needs to be one bill that says this is
how we're going to dress background
checks and everybody else just refer
it's all referral so this
congratulations to your dietician
compact you are plowing the field first
on this and um if we'll we'll go from
there so okay thank you chair and
committee sponsor G thank you very much
so there we go so perfect all right so
our so as a committee then our
recommendation on 145 is
to amend the background check part
for
um or this one it is 80 it is 82 82 okay
okay marvelous so that I mean we don't
necessarily we can go get all formal and
make motions on that um but that's I
just think we should make a motion to
continue with this to the next meeting
because we still have a subcommittee
meeting on the other bill
in fact we might have a subcommittee
meeting on 82 and 85 next that that is
where going that would definitely clean
everything up the only thing is though
just so you know when I do that because
because we're going to have to talk
about this when we when we schedule that
I have to include this on the list just
so just so you know it's gonna we can't
we can't start discussing H Bill 145 in
a subcommittee hearing on House Bill 82
right that's just not appropriate we
have to provide notices that so and
that's fine but just just for your
scheduling and and um you know paying
attention to things Point that's that's
why that will pop up do you have
something first director I uh I was just
I got a um Return to Sender email I sent
an email to the four of you with the
rules for the social work but
representative long your email came back
that it was unable to send to you but
it's your general court email so that's
I'll send
it so I I I'd be happy for the committee
to send it to you but I'm not I'm not
sure if that's a clerk or an IT thing
but they changed my email because the it
system was confused by there being two
Patrick Longs in the system okay so it
is now Patrick n. long and not patrick.
n. long it's Pat yeah oh I see okay so
there's there's only one period yeah
okay
I um so they um you may want to the link
when I click on your representative
profile has still has the the second dot
so it it is coming back returned to
Sender if you like to let them office is
it's in the basement yeah I apologize
for bringing that up in public but I
want to make sure you have it no no
that's his legislative email that's
that's not a that's not a private um yes
that's not a private
email okay so it sounds like we have we
have
um some sure we I'm just I move to
adjourn and I will I will second that in
the in the sense that we have um we seem
to have a path forward on both of these
as to what we're thinking and uh and
we'll uh and we'll go from there we'll
add We'll add 145 to the 8285
um meeting that will probably happen
it's going to happen in the next two
weeks so I just have to go through and
look at our schedule um it will not be
after session next session we will not
have time for that I that I can assure
you so uh we and we'll go from there
guys
e